>> DANIEL FRIEDMAN: All right, welcome. It is
active livestream. Number 510.
This is the background in context.
First discussion for canonical neural
networks performance active inference by
Isa Mara et al. It's October 26,
2022. Welcome to the active inference
institute. We're a participatory online
institute that is communicating,
learning and plasticity applied active
inference. You can find us at some of
the links on the page. This is recorded
in an archive livestream, so please
provide us with feedback so we can
improve our work. All backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome and will be
following video etiquette for Solo
Livestreams head to Active Inference.org
to learn how to get involved with Active
Inference Institute projects today.
It's the first of several discussions
that we'll have on the paper. Canonical
neural networks perform active
inference. 2022 by Tequia Isomura,
Hijacki Shimazaki and Karl Friston
The video is just an introduction to
some of the ideas. It's not a review or
final word. There will be an overview of
the structure of the paper and then
we'll go through many of the set point.
Also just to disclaim, there's many,
many other and better resources to learn
about neural networks. So I would very
much welcome those with a technical
understanding of neural networks and or
some of the more applied computational
or otherwise aspects of neural networks.
It would be awesome to have them on for
the dot one and the dot two, because it
was not an area I was familiar with and
so hope that I can hear more from the
authors in our coming weeks and others.
I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in
California, and this will just be a solo
zero, which I guess hasn't happened in a
while in the making of
this. Here are some of the generated art
prompts area 51 Active Inference Brea.
51 neural network. Area 51 active
inference. Ant Brea. 51 Active Inference
Neural Network just some interesting
images coming out of stable diffusion.
So as to some big questions that the
paper is addressing and that one might
be interested in to come to the paper.
How can artificial neural networks be
understood as generic optimization
processes and what is the correspondence
between hemodynamics and modern
statistical inference methods?
Other big questions are about the
history and next steps of the enmeshment
of natural intelligence, eg.
Neuroscience and artificial
intelligence, as well as, of course,
whether to even play into this kind of
distinction at all and have different
integrated intelligence frameworks. And
one paper where any of the authors or
anyone who has kind of resonated with
this work is recent by Zidore at all
2022 towards the Next Generation
artificial Intelligence catalyzing the
NeuroAI Revolution and so this is a
bunch of authors. And so it's
interesting just to quote in terms of
what some areas of discourse are saying
right now, which is neuroscience has
long been an important driver of
progress in artificial intelligence AI.
We propose that to accelerate progress
in AI, we must invest in fundamental
research in NeuroAI. So that's one way
to lead some of the developments that
are happening in the paper we'll discuss
what does it mean to be particular but
generic? That's a phrase used in the
paper, so maybe that's kind of a jumping
off point. And then how can active
inference help us understand the past,
present and future here of the
interface with neural networks,
statistics and neural AI?
Here's the abstract.
This work considers a class of canonical
neural networks comprising rate coding
models where neural activity and
plasticity minimize a common cost
function and plasticity is modulated
with a certain delay. We show that such
neural networks implicitly perform
active inference and learning to
minimize the risk associated with future
outcomes. Mathematical analyses
demonstrate that this biological
optimization can be cast as maximization
of model evidence or equivalently
minimization of variational free energy
under the wellknown form of a partially
observed Markov decision process model.
This equivalence indicates that the
delayed modularity of heavy and
plasticity accompanied with adaptation
of firing thresholds is a sufficient
neuronal substrate to attain Bayes
optimal inference and control. We
corroborated this proposition using
numerical analyses of maze tasks.
This theory offers a universal
characterization of canonical neural
networks in terms of Bayesian belief
updating and provides insight into the
neuronal mechanisms underlying planning
and adaptive behavioral control.
Here is the roadmap I'll be driving. On
the right side of the road, there's an
introduction and a table with glossary
of different expressions used. Then
there's the Results sections, which has
first an overview of equivalence between
neural networks and variational base
active inference formulated using a
postdiction of past decisions.
Canonical neural networks perform active
inference and numerical simulations. So
they work on the interface between
neural networks and variational Bayesian
methods and start with a more
theoretical and mathematical background
and then eventually present some maze
simulations that are in MATLAB. Then
there's a discussion, and then the
methods section is following the
discussion and it has the subsections
generative model variational free energy
inference and learning, neural networks,
simulations and data analysis. And I
think that I have kept to the right
color codes consistently from here on
forward. The black quotes are the direct
quotes from the paper Bleu quotes quotes
are related to perception,
orange for action, complete class
theorems and neural networks together in
purple. And then red is commentary and
then the highlighting for red is related
to the variational methods,
but it's kind of redish.
Okay, the papers canonical neural
networks perform active inference by the
authors listed previously. It's in
communications biology from 2022.
And the key aims of the paper are
laid out well in the first paragraph.
So that's in black and other colors.
And here the red is just kind of
settling point initial conversation with
the paper and connecting a little bit
more to some previous streams before we
go more into the specifics of the paper.
The sentient behavior of biological
organisms is characterized by
optimization biological organisms
recognize the state of their environment
by optimizing internal representations
of the external environmental dynamics
generating sensory inputs. So that's the
sensory recognition model. In addition,
they optimize their behavior for
adaptation to the environment thereby
increasing their probability of survival
and reproduction. So that is bringing
the entire active and inactive control
theory. Formal theories of action.
Action selections. Planning and planning
as inference all of these actionoriented
pragmatic term type ideas come into play
when this actionorange aspect is brought
in and it is.
Must be. Should be. Etc oriented towards
survival and persistence otherwise we
don't see that kind of thing for long
over appropriate definitions for thing
and long. Et cetera. And this few
sentences that the paper begins with
summarizes a common theme in actinF
which is that there's basically two
pathways towards proficiency in the
niche. There's changing the mind, which
is the perceptual and learning and then
there's changing the world through
action. And that kind of integration of
inference, cognitive inference, whether
it's perceptual or learning or other and
action as enacted is part of the
active formula and shared with other
areas. This biological selforganization
is typically formulated as the
minimization of cost functions where in
a gradient descent on a cost function
furnishes neurodynamics and synaptic
plasticity. So they are working with
a framework where the way that this
perception action flow is tractable
computationally either just for our
current computers so that we can
implement simulations and data fitting
or whether more fundamentally like this
is the computational context of action
they're suggesting there's a way to
think of it in terms of a cost function
minimization and also note like
minimization maximization. In a way
they're interchangeable because there's
just sometimes negative signs that can
flip them. So it's the same energy and
fitness landscape that is being
navigated whether you're minimizing to
the bottom of the bowl and thinking of
action selection that way and inference
or whether you're climbing to the top of
the hill gradient descent. Gradient
ascent they're both kind of two sides of
the same .2
fundamental issues remain to be
established. Namely so this is what the
paper is saying they're filling the gap
in literature the characterization of
the dynamics of an arbitrary neural
network as a generic optimization
process and the correspondence between
such neural dynamics and statistical
inference found in applied mathematics
and machine learning. The present work
addresses these issues by demonstrating
that a class of canonical neural
networks of rate coding models is
functioning as and thus universally
characterized in terms of variational
bayesian inference under a particular
but generic form of the generative
model. This is maybe the
only slide that has resources from too
far a field from paper. Well,
almost a few more. It's just on neural
networks. The search on a very common
search tool resulted in five
plus million results for what are neural
networks? And the first one was three
Bleu one brown in 2017 which is just a
nice YouTube video as they very often
make with these beautiful renditions,
and it's a very great video. And there's
many, many others. A neural network is a
network or circuit of biological
neurons, and that is variously purely
computational and or biological
map territory stuff. And they
can be thought of as nodes and edges,
which are the firing rates
and the connections between the
biological neurons being modeled as
weights between nodes. A positive
weight reflects an excitatory
connection, while negative values mean
inhibitory connections. And here is data
coming in and ending up activating
different neurons in this final layer.
So this is kind of doing inference in a
neural network, and then there's an
action part. Okay, the paper
says variational Bayesian inference
offers a unified explanation for
inference learning, prediction,
decision making and the evolution of
biological form, which can be considered
over multiple timescales. So this
returns to the earlier theme of like
exteroception action and persistence
within and among generations. And the
citations that are provided here for
this are Friston, Kilner Harrison 2006
and Friston 2010,
both very classic acne FEP
papers, just to show one figure from
each here's from the first citation
with a winged snowflake, where if the
snowflake ends up being somewhere that's
too warm, that's not able for it to
maintain the structure, then it melts,
melts into a dew, etc. And it
must be acting as if in one way or
another, it's staying above that phase
boundary. That's how it's statistically
identified, it's how it's
autogenetically identified,
functionally identified.
And then here is one of the kind
of path setting figures in the first
and 2010 paper with a tree of many
different areas to connect to,
informalisms to represent as including
probabilistic, neural coding,
Bayesian brain,
optimal control and value learning.
These three and others can be
really seen at play in this paper.
The kind of inference variational basing
methods use rests upon a generative
model that expresses a hypothesis about
the generation of sensory input.
Perception and behavior can then be read
as optimizing the evidence for a
generative model inherent in sensory
exchanges for the environment, and
that's the integration of perception and
action within a single imperative in
terms of if only computation.
And that is described more on this
slide, which one can pause and read,
but the rest of the quotes are from the
paper.
One eformalism that
I had no familiarity with before this
paper and associated readings and
conversations with Ali was the Complete
Class Theorem. So it would be great
for anyone who's familiar with Complete
Class Theorem to help a little bit here,
but here's some interesting things that
I came across crucially from the paper
as a corollary of the Complete Class
Theorem citations 19 through 21. Any
neural network minimizing a class
function can be viewed as performing
variational Bayesian inference under
some prior beliefs. Here are the
citations 19 through 21 from
1940 719 81 2013,
and also found some
interesting resources. So quoting from
this less wrong post linked here,
dutch book defines belief as willingness
to bet and Money Pump defines preference
as willingness to pay. This is in terms
of the foundational arguments for a
Bayesian Epistemological worldview.
Hope that's correct. Again, it would be
good to hear from anyone who knows more
here, but in terms of different ways
that one can consider the Bayesian
proposition, which perhaps these are
even better to use than referencing any
person's last name. Because the
interesting thing will be the different
lenses that these different framings
on Bayesian probabilities are
interpreted as. Just like what a Pvalue
is interpreted as in the frequentist
worldlessly, like a beta factor
interpretation. So Dutch book defines
belief as willingness to bet and Money
pump defines preferences willingness to
pay. In doing so, both arguments put the
justification of decision theory into
hypothetical exploitation scenarios
which are not quite the same as the
actual decisions we face. If these were
the best justifications for
consequentialism we could muster, I
would be somewhat dissatisfied, but
would likely leave it alone.
Fortunately, a better alternative
exists. The complete Class theorem.
So here's an image from that
post possible world states
observation likelihood maps to the
possible observations hashtag a matrix,
then decisionmaking rule may be
probabilistic action selection as
inference a possible actions
affordances. And here we commonly
see the loop being closed from actions
to world states like through the B
matrix changing how the world changes
through time. And here these are both
going to be mapped to a loss function l
a real valued score from taking an
action A when the world turned out to be
theta realized theta. So that's quite an
interesting framing and there were
some other useful posts online. And from
this Zhang blog the
argument boils down to if you agree with
expected utility as your objective,
then you have to be Bayesian. In a
nutshell, a strategy is inadmissible if
there exists another state that is as
good in all situations and strictly
better in at least one. If you want your
strategy to be admissible, it should be
equivalent to a Bayes estimator Complete
Class Theorems. Only Bayes strategies
are admissible and admissible strategies
are Bayes. So there's
probably a lot of interpretations of
this, but it seems kind of related to
optimal control or Bayes optimal
inference, perhaps a little bit more
keenly. So these are some next
two slides were contributed by Ali, so
if you or if anyone familiar in this
area wants to come on and the discussion
would be great, but Ali pointed me
to this book fundamentals of Bayesian
Epistemology by title Bomb 2022
table of contents shown here, and some
challenges and objections to Bayesian
Epistemology are listed which can be
read. And then also there's some
quite interesting logical structures
which can be read here in terms of their
premise, theorem and conclusion. In the
areas of arguments for Bayesianism being
representation theorem, argument for
probabilism, the dutch book argument for
probabilism and the Gradational accuracy
argument for probabilism. So pretty
interesting. Back to the
paper they wrote we have previously
introduced a reverse engineering
approach that identifies a class of
biologically plausible cost functions
for neural networks. Citation 22
previous Paper of Isomura Karl Friston
2020 the paper was reverse engineering
neural networks to characterize their
cost functions, the abstracts shown
here. But this letter considers a class
of biologically plausible cost functions
for neural networks using generative
models based on partially observable
Markov decision processes.
We show that neural activity and
plasticity perform Bayesian inference
and learning respectively by maximizing
model evidence. So this is a precursor
paper from 2020 that is cited and
foundational for the 2022 paper.
Here are some figures from that paper.
They have comparisons among Markov
decision process scheme and a neural
network. For example, a Markov decision
process scheme expressed as a formy
factor graph based on the formulation
in Friston. So here is the Markov
decision process as a formy factor
graph and on the right side is the
neural network with the hidden state
sensory inputs and neural activity and
some figures and
concordances.
And they wrote in this context, the
neural network can in principle be used
as a dynamic causal model to estimate
threshold, constants and implicit
priors. This reverse engineering speaks
to estimating the priors used by real
neuronal systems under ideal Bayesian
assumptions, sometimes referred to as
metabasian inference. So they're
laying out their research agenda and
much of the work is going to reference
this earlier paper and other work. And
then there's also some new integrations
and especially the maze simulation in
this paper, and probably more so let's
find out. Referring to
the earlier paper, this foundational
work identified a class of cost
functions for single layer field feed
forward neural networks of state coding
models with a sigmoid or logistic
activation function. We subsequently
demonstrated that mathematical
equivalence between the class of cost
functions for such neural networks and
variational free energy under a
particular form of the generative model,
which is similar broadly to what the 22
paper dot. Two, this equivalent licenses
variational Bayesian inference as a
fundamental optimization process that
underlies both the dynamics and function
of such neural networks.
However, it remains to be established
whether the active inference is an apt
explanation for any given neural network
that actively exchanges with its
environment. In this paper, we address
this inactive or control aspect to
complete the formal equivalent of neural
network optimization and the free energy
principle. So this earlier
work was not including
action. And so this paper's key
addition, as I understand it,
hopefully, is that they bring
action more formally into the
model. And it would
be interesting to know like what else is
that change associated with? Or what
else happens or doesn't?
Here's some more text about
the approach that they're going to take,
and many of these details are going to
be addressed later on.
Here's table one glossary of
expressions, so these will also
be broadly addressed later
on.
Maybe it's useful though just to read
the first one a canonical neural network
in this work, the canonical neural
network is defined by differential
equations of neural activity derived as
reduction of realistic neuron models
through some approximations which give a
network of rate coding neurons with a
sigmoid activation function. In
particular, we consider networks
comprising a middle layer that involves
recurrent connections and the output
layer that provides feedback responses
to the environment. So some category
of neural network architecture or
anatomy, physiology, whatever with
sensory, cognitive and actionlike
features in an environment or a
generative process. So the results
section,
they write an overview of equivalence
between neural networks and variational
base. First we summarize the formal
correspondence between neural networks
and variational base. A biological agent
is formulated here as an autonomous
system comprising a network of rate
coding neurons. Figure one A so here's a
small figure one A. We'll see it larger
based upon the assumptions which will be
brought up later on in a different
fuller form. The update rule for the ith
component of phi, which is the
internal states so the cognitive states
and the output layer y. So middle layer
x and output layer y,
these can be seen as the cognitive and
the actinF selective aspects which are
the autonomous states in contrast
to the particular state of the active
inference entity which is the whole
blanket, and the cognitive states so
including the sensory state. But the
sensory states can't be directly
controlled, however action can influence
them. And so that's what closes the
causal loop and that
set of the particular states comprising
the autonomous states the update rule
for the ith component of phi is derived
as the gradient descent on the cost
function. So the change in that by
sub I is proportional to a derivative
on the loss function. This determines
the dynamics of neural networks
including their activity and plasticity.
So. L common loss function O
observations sensory states by
internal state comprising the middle and
output layer neural activity that's the
rate coding part and synaptic strength w
the parameterization and other free
parameters including that that
characterize L. Then there's the output
layer activity y is determining the
network's actions or decisions delta o
x and y y is outputting action
environment generative process hidden
state passing observations to the
sensory cognitive active layers the
neural network and that is analogous
topologically to the variational
Bayesian formulation in
figure one B. And so left side gradient
descent on a neural network cost
function L determines the dynamics of
neural activity and plasticity. Thus L
is sufficient to characterize the neural
network and then being shown
next to on the right side variational
free energy minimization allows an agent
to self organize, to encode the hidden
states of the external milieu and to
make decisions minimizing future risk.
Here, variational free energy F is
sufficient to characterize active
inference and behaviors of the agent.
So sentence structure parallelism,
and these two schemes
or approaches being Linsker and applied
is a focus of this area.
So neural networks are minimizing the
cost function L. In contrast,
variational Bayesian inference depicts a
process of updating the prior
distribution of external states P of
theta, so the corresponding posterior
distribution Q of theta based upon the
sequence of observations. And we see
other familiar terms from discussions on
variational DAGs like minimization of
surprise. And there's some more model
details shown here. A few points are
about choosing the family of
distributions that one is doing
variational inference with, and that
allows for the gradient update rules in
that family of distributions to be maze
simpler. For example, choosing a linear
regression with an L two norm. At the
very least, you can say that it has a
simple decision rule for being fit.
I'm sure there's like also counter
arguments and other algorithms that are
better and so on. But just to say that a
simple decision rule in a known family
of distributions can often be good
enough as an approximation, if not more
crucially. According to the Complete
Class theorem from earlier, a dynamical
system that minimizes its cost function
can be viewed as performing Bayesian
inference under some generative model
and prior beliefs. The Complete Class
theorem goes on to describe it ensures
the presence of a generative model that
formally corresponds to the above
defined neural network characterized by
L. Hence, this speaks to the equivalence
between the class of neural network cost
functions and variational free energy
under such a generative model equation
one loss function on the time
series of observations comma parameters.
Three ines is defined as f the free
energy function on the same O
through time comma parameters.
So there's a parallel being shown
defined wherein the internal states
of a network by encode or parameterize
the posterior expectation theta.
This mathematical equivalence means that
an arbitrary neural network in the class
under consideration is implicitly
performing active inference through
variational free energy minimization and
more is written. But this is one of many
statements that will be made
corresponding to correspondences
between neural network loss function,
generative model, active free energy
minimization, and associated formalisms.
Note that being able to characterize the
neural network in terms of maximizing
model evidence lends it in
explainability in the sense that
internal neural network states and
parameters encode Bayesian beliefs or
expectations about the causes of
observations. In other words, the
generative model explains how outcomes
were generated. However, the Complete
Class theorem does not specify the form
of a generative model for any given
neural network. To address this issue
in the remainder of the paper, we
formulate active inference using a
particular form of partially observable
Markov decision processes PMDP models
whose states take binary values. So this
is one of several simplifications is one
way to see it or areas for later
generalization. Figure Two
in this section, we define a generative
model and ensuing variational free
energy that corresponds to a class of
canonical neural networks that will be
considered in the subsequent section.
The internal model is expressed as a
discrete state space in the form of a
POMDP figure two. So to
make figure two larger,
there's a lot to probably say about this
bigger. I'll just note
that the caption is informative and
some of the highlighted lines. It'll be
awesome to have the author and other
people who's familiar with some of the
differences and symmetries between the,
for example, bottom and top,
above and below the observations, and
also about the role of time and what
these two risks are. What is fictive
causality?
Here's more details on that POMDP then
equation two. This is in this section
active inference formulated using a
postdiction of past decisions. So if it
was a prediction of future decisions,
it's the opposite, a postdiction of past
decisions. Hence, we define the
generative model as follows PO delta
s gamma theta, which is the model of
observations decisions, observations
decisions, hidden states risk and theta
theta equals A, b and C constitutes
a set of parameters and more details are
provided. This is the familiar notation
with some slight differences that will
be described. And equation two reflects
the factorizability and the
dimensions and the kind of computational
tractability expression.
So that would be interesting to also
learn about like under what conditions
can this joint distribution be
factorized? Under what simplifications
or constructions the
agent is making decisions to minimize a
risk function capital gamma that's on
the bottom of figure two, victim
causality. Leading to this gamma.
Coming from that gamma,
equation three is shown.
And to characterize the optimal
decisions as minimizing expected risk in
our POMDP model, we use effective
mapping from the current risk gamma to
past decisions that's that retro
addictive fictive causality. Although
this is not the true causality in the
real generative process that generates
sensory data. Here we intend to model
the manner that an agent subjectively
evaluates its previous decisions after
experiencing their consequences. This
fictive causality is expressed in the
form of a canonical distribution. So it
could be other families hypothetically.
But this equation three is describing
fictive causality and this interesting
sign indicates the element
noise division operator. Also note
throughout the manuscript the overline
variable indicates one minus that
variable. So gamma bar equals one minus
gamma. Or it can be understood as the
complement of a statistical probability
probability of a happening and the
probability of not a happening in that
one way.
Importantly, the agent needs to keep
selecting good decisions while avoiding
bad decisions. To this end, equation
three supposes that the agent learns
from the failure of decisions by
assuming that the bad decisions were
sampled from the opposite of the optimal
policy. Mapping some more details
and then by convention, active inference
uses C to denote the prior preference.
That's how we've seen the C variable
in many models as preferences. Prior
Preference this work uses C to denote a
mapping to determine a decision
depending on the previous state. Herein
the prior preference is implicit in the
risk function due to construction.
C does not explicitly appear
in the inference. Thus it is omitted in
the following formulations. So that's a
key point about the notation of the
variable C and something kind of maybe
interesting to explore. Equation Four
variational Bayesian inference refers to
the process that optimizes the posterior
belief q of theta based on the mean
field approximation q of theta is
expressed as and here is the
factorization representation of
the q of theta variational and another
notation. Note throughout the
manuscript, bold case variables such as
bold s subtow denote the posterior
expectations of the corresponding italic
case random variables and some
more details about the model. For
example, for simplicity, here we suppose
that state and decision prior D and E
are fixed, so one could imagine they
don't have to be, but for simplicity
they will be. Here,
under the abovedefined generative model
and posterior beliefs, the ensuing
variational free energy is analytically
expressed as follows equation Five this
is a variational free energy F and
recall equation one that it is being
connected to, juxtapose with,
etc. The loss function the
gradient descent on variational free
energy updates the posterior beliefs
about hidden states s decisions, delta
and parameters theta. The optimal
posterior beliefs that minimize
variational free energy are obtained as
the fixed point of the implicit gradient
descent, which ensures that change in
F with respect to the change in hidden
state through time equals zero. And some
more definitions. All of them are zero,
that one might be an O, but they're all
zero. And this is saying the ball
rolls to the bottom of the hill in this
gradient descent, and when the rate of
change is zero, then that is a fixed
point attractor like dynamic, and that
can be used as a way to
incrementally fit statistical models
like the loss function is used to
incrementally fit neural networks.
To explicitly demonstrate the formal
correspondence with the cost function
for neural networks considered in the
next section, we further transformed the
variational free energy as follows some
details Using these relationships,
equation five is transformed into the
form shown in Figure three. See the
Methods section variational Free Energy
for further details. In what follows,
we demonstrate that the internal states
of canonical neural networks encode
posterior beliefs. Here's figure three
on the top from the caption figure three
is the mathematical equivalence between
variational free energy and neural
network cost functions depicted by one
to one correspondence of their
components. Top variational free energy
transformed from equation five using the
Bayes theorem and foreshadowing.
Equation seven. Using this relationship,
equation seven is transformed into the
form presented at the bottom of the figure.
So here's f variational free energy and
L the neural network cost function and
different elements as they're
represented here with some
resonances and concordance and beyond
which we can explore, they're being
shown to be equivalent. And it was
in the conversation preparing for this
dot zero with Dean, where we
saw this as some chromosomes.
In this section, canonical Neural
Networks Perform Active Inference in
this section we identify the neuronal
substrates that correspond to components
of the active inference scheme defined
above. We consider a class of two
layered neural networks with reafferent
connections in the middle layer. Figure
one a those are those connections with
loops recurrent in the middle layer.
The modeling of the networks in this
section, referred to as canonical neural
networks, is based on the following
three assumptions that reflect
physiological knowledge. One gradient
descent on a cost function l,
determines the updates of neural
activity and synaptic weights. Method
Section neural Networks Neural Two
assumption two neural activity is
updated by the weighted sum of inputs
and its fixed point is expressed in a
form of a sigmoid or logistic function.
And assumption three, a modulatory
factor mediate synaptic plasticity in a
post hoc manner.
They write based upon assumption two,
which is neural activity is updated by
the weighted sum of inputs and its fixed
point is expressed in the form of a
sigmoid or logistic function. Based on
assumption two, we formulate neural
activity in the middle layer and output
layer the autonomous states as
follows equation six
without loss of generality,
equation six can be cast as the gradient
descent on cost function l. Such a cost
function can be identified by simply
integrating the righthand side of
equation six with respect to x and y,
consistent with previous treatments.
Citations because neural activity and
synaptic plasticity minimize the same
cost function l, the derivatives of l
must generate the modulated synaptic
plasticity under these constraints,
reflecting assumptions one through
three, a class of cost functions is
identified as follows equation seven
loss function. Awesome to hear somebody
read this directly.
So there's a firing rate aspect that's
related to neural firing in the short
term more perceptual aspect
of function. And there's a slower
neurotransmitter neuroglial
factormediated learning
over perhaps a different time scale and
with some different features, and
they're being included as a joint model
of inference. And here that is being
connected to doing inference on action.
Synaptic Plasticity in Neural Networks
so synaptic plasticity rules conjugate
to the above rate coding model can now
be expressed as a gradient descent on
the same cost function l, according to
assumption one, equations eight and nine
showing that neural networks
can integrate those modes of
firing rate like and synaptic
modulatory like.
Neural networks. Cost Functions and
Variational Free Energy Based on
the above considerations, we now
establish the formal correspondence
between the neural network cost function
and variational free energy. Using under
the aforementioned three minimal
assumptions, we identified the neural
network cost function as equation seven.
Equation seven can be transformed.
Hinton the form shown in figure three
bottom using sigmoid functions of
synaptic strengths. So equation seven
loss function transformed into the
form shown in figure three bottom.
Hence,
this class of cost functions for
canonical neural networks is formally
homologous to variational free energy
under the particular form of the POMDP
generative model defined in the previous
section. We obtain this result based on
analytic derivations without reference
to the complete class theorem, thereby
confirming the proposition of equation
one loss function and free energy.
This in turn suggests that any canonical
neural network in this class is
implicitly performing active inference.
Table two summarizes the correspondence
between the quantities of the neural
network and their homologues in
variational Bayes. So two,
a great concordance table.
On the left side, neural network
formation. On the right side,
variational Bayes formulation.
So just like in figure three,
we had the two
long lines. Then table
two, we have rotated 90
degrees and the variables for
different parts of these models
are laid next to each other.
So what papers of neural
networks can we make active
models for? Is it already done or
is there just one script that needs to
be done? And then conversely, what
interesting, variational Bayesian models
have interesting applications or
some other value or information gain
from being cast as neural networks or
integrating neural networks into what
had previously been only analytical
variational Bayesian models as well as
the empirical data fitting aspect which
is related that's highlighted by the
authors. So, in summary,
when a neural network minimizes the cost
function with respect to its activity
and plasticity the network selforganizes
to furnish responses that minimize the
risk implicit in the cost function,
this biological optimization is
identical to variational free energy
minimization under a particular form of
the POMDP model. Hence, this equivalence
indicates that minimizing the expected
risk through variational free energy
minimization is an inherent property of
canonical neural networks featuring
delayed modulation of hebion plasticity.
Okay, brief seconds to
view some image memes and
take a breath in a stretch.
On the left side, the top panel says
Epineural network is implicitly
performing active inference.
That's awesome. In the middle image
meme, one simply makes a neural network
and it is implicitly performing active
inference. Also question mark.
And then in the right image meme, there
are two pieces of paper neural network
and implicit performance of active
inference. Corporate needs you to find
the differences between this picture and
this picture. And here is the paper.
They're the same picture.
So the previous sections have
successfully extended the
variational Bayes meets inference.
Neural network results
from the 2020 paper with an action loop
and a loss function only on the
autonomous states. So that was the
conceptual and technical feature
that this paper brought in.
Again, it'll be awesome to hear the
author describe it more and differently.
And then in this part of the paper,
they turn from that kind of analytical
theoretical towards some numerical
simulations in MATLAB.
Here we demonstrate the performance of
canonical neural networks using maze
tasks. As an example of a delayed reward
task, the agent comprised the
aforementioned canonical neural
networks. Figure four a thus it
implicitly performs active inference by
minimizing variational free energy. So
now some entity or agent is going to be
constructed and numerically simulated to
support some of the aspects
of their model and point towards utility
in other settings. So here's figure four
simulation of neural networks solving
maze tasks.
In part A, there is the architecture of
the agent sensory input layer O
of T synaptic weights
into the middle layer x internal states
and the output layer y decision action
with risk gamma of T.
The sensation comes in a neural network
then outputs a decision.
There's some task that the
entity must perform
which is to
move towards the goal from the start
across this lateral maze.
So one could imagine that if it
were just a hallway with no maze
features, simple strategies would be
very overfit but effective like always
move simply towards the goal. Whereas in
more complex settings, which this is an
example of where there's uncertainty
as well as many local optima.
So one has to sometimes take one or two
or three or four or more steps or
however many to get closer to the goal
and sometimes may not know, for example
how long those backtracking situations
are going to be and all these other
complexities for which this maze example
is symbolic
of. So maybe there's some interesting
mythos maze connections and
computational and here's some
performance measures on the maze task
with the neural network entity. This
way, before training,
the agent moved to a random direction,
each step resulting in a failure to
reach the goal position right end within
the time limit. During training, the
neural network updated synaptic
strengths depending on its neural
activity and ensuing outcomes I e.
Risk. This training comprised
a cycle of action and learning phases.
This treatment renders neural activity
and adaptive behaviors of the agent
highly explainable and manipulatable in
terms of the appropriate prior beliefs
implicit in firing thresholds for a
given task or environment. In other
words, these results suggest that firing
thresholds are the neuronal substrates
that encode state and decision priors as
predicted. Mathematically big if true.
Furthermore, when the updating of
parameters is slow across these two now
linked domains parameters of the
variational Bayesian autonomous state
inference and the neural network loss
function parameters when the updating
of these parameters are slow in relation
to the experimental observations, the
parameters can be estimated through
Bayesian inference based on empirically
observed neuronal response curve method.
Section data Analysis for details using
this approach, we estimated implicit
prior E, which is encoded by PSI from
sequences of neural activity generated
from the synthetic neural networks used
in the simulations reported in figure
four. We confirmed that this estimator
was a good approximation to the true e.
So that's also pretty interesting. This
is showing they don't just
lay out this architecture and show
that it's possible to fulfill this maze
task with the best whatever.
It's not a classification accuracy
imperative alone.
They're describing that from empirically
observed neuronal responses,
which is to say the experimenters
observation the sequences of neural
activity generated from the synthetic
neural networks used in that figure
numerically. So statistically,
that estimator was a good approximation
to the true e. Figure five a so
here's figure five.
Estimation of implicit priors enables
the prediction of subsequent learning.
So that's pretty interesting and
will be great to hear what each of the
axes are and what all the variables
mean. With this
setup in place, they did some numerical
validation and talked a little bit more
about fitting data from this
simulation model.
Here's the discussion section. So the
first paragraph of the discussion
biological organisms formulate plans to
minimize future risks. In this work, we
captured this characteristic in
biologically plausible terms under
minimal assumptions. We Deneve simple
differential equations that can be
plausibly interpreted in terms of a
neural network architecture that entails
degrees of freedom with respect to
certain free parameters, e. G firing
threshold. These three parameters play
the role of prior beliefs in variational
Bayesian formulation. Thus,
the accuracies of inferences and
decisions depend upon prior beliefs
implicit in neural networks. And here's
some more stable diffusion ant neural
network ant gain neural network
so some more summarization of what they
did based on the view of the brain as an
agent that performs Bayesian inference.
Internal representation of Bayesian
belief updating have been proposed which
enables neural networks to store and
recall spiking sequences eight learn
temporal dynamics and causal hierarchy
nine. Extract hidden causes ten, solve
maze tasks eleven, and make plans to
control robots twelve. So citations
eight through twelve listed here.
In these approaches, the update rules
are generally derived from Bayesian cost
functions e. G variational free energy.
However, the precise relationship
between these update rules and the
neural activity and plasticity of
canonical neural networks has yet to be
fully established.
We identified a onetoone correspondence
between neural network architecture and
a specific POMDP implicit in that
network. Equation two speaks
to a unique POMDP model consistent with
the neural network architecture defined
in equation six, where their
correspondences are summarized in table
two and the figures. This means
that our scheme can be used to identify
the form of the POMDP given an
observable circuit structure. Moreover,
the free parameters zhat parameterize
equation six can be estimated using
equation 24. This means that the
generative model and ensuring
variational free energy can in principle
be reconstructed from empirical data.
This offers a formal characterization of
implicit Bayesian models entailed by
neural circuits, thereby enabling a
prediction of subsequent learning. So
what can be done with this?
What is this new?
What is new here? Does this second
selection fully
establish the precise relationship
between these update rules and the
neural activity and plasticity of
canonical neural networks.
Here is a discussion section on hebion
plasticity, neurotransmitters and glia
with a lot of citations listed.
And here is just one interesting
followon discussion from the
computational aspects. Neurocognitive
and computational aspects of heavy and
plasticity is these modulations have
been observed empirically with various
neuromodulators and neurotransmitters
such as Dopamine, Noradrenaline,
Lescreen, and GABA, as well as glial
factors. So here's a picture by
Alexandra Michaelova Cultured astrocytes
release, signaling and growth factors
that regulate proper neuronal
development so Cool,
Glial, Pick,
Dopamine and reinforcement learning. In
particular, a delayed modulation of
synaptic plasticity is well known with
Dopamine neurons citations 35 through
37. Those citations are
listed here. This speaks to a learning
scheme that is conceptually distinct
from standard reinforcement learning
algorithms, such as the temporal
difference learning with actorcritic
model based on state action value
objective function. Please see the
previous work citation 50 for a detailed
comparison between active inference and
reinforcement learning that is state
ball par Karl Friston active inference
demystified and compared from 2021 and
that's also active model stream number
two. One, we mathematically demonstrated
that such plasticity enhances the
association between the pre post mapping
and the future value of the modulatory
factor, where the latter is cast as a
risk function. This means that
postsynaptic neurons selforganized to
react in a manner that minimizes future
risk. So the neural network had three
layers. It's the second and the third
layer, not the initial sensory layer,
but the second and the third layer, the
cognitive and the active states, which
are the autonomous states of the
particular state. So that's quite
interesting the self organization
of synaptic neurons to
react in a manner that minimizes future
risk. Crucially, this computation
corresponds formally to variational
Bayesian inference under a particular
form of Pom DP generative model,
suggesting that the delayed modulation
of Hebbian plasticity is a realization
of active inference and regionally
specific projections of neuromodulators
may allow each brain region to optimize
activity to minimize risk and leverage a
hierarchical generative model implicit
in cortical and subcortical hierarchies.
This is reminiscent of theories of
neuromodulator and meta learning
developed previously. Citation 52 Doya
2002 metal learning and neuromodulator
cool. Our work may be potentially useful
when casting these theories in terms of
generative model and variational free
energy minimization.
They then return the discussion to the
complete class theorem and neural
networks. So the Complete Class Theorem
same citations from before ensures that
any neural network whose activity and
plasticity minimize the same cost
function can be cast as performing
Bayesian inference. However,
identifying the implicit generative
model that underwrites any canonical
neural network is a more delicate
problem, because the theorem does not
specify a form of the generative model
for a given canonical neural network.
Which is pretty interesting. Is that to
say that the form of the generative
model as modeled is
different in what ways? From the given
canonical neural network, the posterior
beliefs are largely shaped by prior
beliefs, making it challenging to
identify the generative model by simply
observing systemic dynamics. To this
end, it is necessary to commit to a
particular form of the generative model
and elucidate how posterior beliefs are
encoded or parameterized by the neural
network states. This work addresses
these issues by establishing a reverse
engineering approach to identify a
generative model implicit in a canonical
neural network, thereby establishing
onetoone correspondences between their
components. Remarkably, a network of
rate coding models with sigmoid
activation function formally corresponds
to a class of POMDP models,
which provide an analytically trackable
example of the present equivalents.
Please refer to the previous paper
citation 22 for further discussion. So
some of the analytical details,
especially on the inferential side
cognitive side burr
captured in the earlier paper.
This paper goes further into mapping
the potentially necessary
and sufficient aspects of the
particular entity, which is to say the
risk minimizing features of the
autonomous states with respect to the
entire particular states, including
sensory states. Connecting that
back of the envelope verbally
expressible formulation to
some complete class of neural networks.
So what's outside of the complete class,
and why? And then what groups within the
class have special or different
features? It is remarkable
that the proposed equivalence can be
leveraged to identify a generative model
zhat an arbitrary neural network
implicitly employs this contrast with
naive neural network models that address
only the dynamics of neural activity and
plasticity. If the generative
model differs from the true generative
process that generates the sensory
input, inferences and decisions are
biased, ie. Suboptimal relative to base
optimal inferences and decisions based
upon the right sort of beliefs. Prior
beliefs in general, the implicit priors
may or may not be equal to the true
priors. Thus, a generic neural network
is typically suboptimal.
Nevertheless, these implicit priors can
be optimized by updating free parameters
e. G threshold factors, phi PSI
based on the gradient descent on cost
function l. By updating the free
parameters, the network will eventually
in principle become Bayes optimal for
any given task. In essence, when the
cost function is minimized with respect
to neural activity, synaptic strengths,
and any other constants that
characterize the cost function,
the cost function becomes equivalent to
variational free energy with the optimal
prior beliefs.
So the cost function for the neural
network activity and synaptic strengths
underlying the loss function are
equivalent to the kind of gradient
descent enabled variational
free energy minimization under the
Bayes optimality scenario
from a risk perspective.
Simultaneously, the expected risk is
minimized because variational free
energy is minimized only when the
precision of the risk gamma is
maximized. C method section generative
model for further details. Very
interesting. They then say
the class of neural networks we consider
can be viewed as a class of reservoir
networks. Citation 54 citation 55
here, the proposed equivalents
could render such reservoir networks
explainable and may provide the optimal
plasticity rules for these networks to
minimize future risk by using the
formal analogy to variational free
energy minimization under the particular
form of PMDP models. A clear
interpretation of reservoir networks
remains an important open issue in
computational neuroscience and machine
learning. So from
Wikipedia reciprocal computing is a
framework for computation derived from
recurrent neural network theory that
maps input signals into higher
dimensional computational spaces through
the dynamics of a fixed nonlinear system
called a reservoir. After the
input signal is fed into the reservoir,
which is treated as a black box, a
simple readout mechanism is trained to
read the state of the reservoir and map
it to the desired output. Then there's
two key benefits of this approach. The
first key benefit of this framework is
that training is performed only at the
readout stage as the reservoir dynamics
are fixed. The second is that the
computational power of naturally
available systems, both classical and
quantum mechanical, can be used to
reduce the effective computational cost.
Here some stable diffusion reservoir
computing, active inference neural
network so
this would be interesting to discuss.
And I remember some Octave institute
participants who are specifically
interested empirical analysis
and hypotheses. They write the
equivalent between neural network
dynamics and gradient flows on
variational free energy is empirically
testable using electrophysiological
recordings or functional imaging of
brain activity. So then
another summarization crucially the
proposed equivalence guarantees that an
arbitrary neural network that minimizes
its cost function, possibly implemented
in biological organisms or neuromorphic
hardware, can be cast as performing
variational Bayesian inference. So to
state it a few more times in the final
paragraph, in summary,
a class of biologically plausible cost
functions for canonical neural networks
can be cast as variational free energy.
Formal correspondences exist between
priors posteriors and cost functions.
This means that canonical neural
networks that optimize their cost
functions implicitly perform active
inference. This approach enables
identification of the implicit
generative model and reconstruction of
variational free energy that neural
networks employ. This means that in
principle, neural activity, behavior and
learning through plasticity can be
predicted under Bayes optimality
assumptions.
There's a code availability statement.
The MATLAB scripts are available at
GitHub in the repo
of the first author, and it would be
awesome for the author or anyone to
bring this working MATLAB script
up and see if we could do some realtime
active inference. Then,
as mentioned earlier, from the roadmap
the methods are following the
discussion. I'll just show the equations
but not go into any details because
there is not time nor familiarity.
So those who have more of one or the
other would be welcome to fill in some
dots because this is a really awesome
and important paper. So I hope that it
can be interpreted and critiqued and
elaborated on and so on by
those with familiarity in both sides of
that free energy loss function.
Equation one generative
model section, many details are
provided. Equation ten is shown. So
larger unpacking of the generative model
section variational free energy many
details are provided, equation 1112,
1314 and 15 section
inference and learning details are
provided. Equations 16 1718
then section on neural networks so
there's just some interesting writing
here. So I wanted to highlight that in
this section we elaborate the one to one
correspondences between components of
the canonical neural networks and
variational Bayes via an analytically
tractable model. So that's the figure
three that we've been returning
to. Neurons respond
quickly to a continuous stimulus stream
with a time scale faster than typical
changes in sensory input. For instance,
a peak of spiking neurons in the visual
cortex of V one appears within 50 and 80
milliseconds after a visual stimulation
citation 62 63, which is substantially
faster than the temporal autocorrelation
timescale of natural image sequences
about 500 milliseconds. Citation 64 65.
So that's pretty interesting.
What is the temporal autocorrelation
timescale of natural sequences?
What timescale do neural firing and
neuroplasticity etc processes
actually occur at? And when
might some type of function at
a given time scale be understood to be
functional or not?
Thus, in other words, downstream of
the fact that neurons respond quickly at
a time scale faster than typical changes
in sensory input, we consider the case
where the neural activity converges to a
fixed point given a sensory stimulus.
We note that the present equivalence is
derived from the differential equations
equation six, but not from its fixed
point. Thus, the equivalence holds true
irrespective of the time constant of
neurons to rephrase neural networks
with a large time constant formally
correspond to Bayesian belief updating
with a large time constant, which
implies an insufficient coverage of the
posterior beliefs. Pretty interesting
related to learning rates and Bayesian
updating rates and all of the nooks
and crannies of Bayesian inference and
the challenges associated with dynamic
uncertain, rugged fitness
and free energy landscapes.
These optimization challenges, which are
addressed differently methodologically,
culturally, etc. In the variational
Bayesian and in the neural cases,
they have to deal with time.
And so all of those different nooks and
crannies mentioned, like catastrophic
learning, catastrophic forgetting,
simply memory, anticipation, attention,
local maxima,
choosing when to play all these higher
order questions are
connected here does that
maze it? What kind of a problem space
now or just what kind of space?
Pretty interesting. And equation
19 202-021-2223 they
have some more details on the
simulation. Maybe we could see the
simulation go and in the last
section data analysis. So this is
kind of returning to that point about
the time constants in Bayesian
and neural network systems when
the belief updating of implicit priors D
and E is slow in relation to
experimental observations, d and E,
which are encoded by phi and PSI,
can be viewed as being fixed over a
short period of time as an analogy to
homeostatic plasticity over longer time
scales. 66 homeostatic Plasticity in the
developing nervous System 2004 very
interesting in light of our recent
discussions on allostasis and other
topics. Thus by and
PSI can be statistically estimated by a
conventional Bayesian inference or
maximum likelihood estimation given a
flat prior based on empirically observed
neuronal responses. In this case, the
estimators of phi and PSI are obtained
as follows Nice equation number 24
mentioned earlier,
so that will be definitely one to look
into more.
Well, I hope you found this
a useful and interesting zero.
I'm looking forward to the discussion
with the author and again, any other
institute participants or those with
knowledge or strong feelings to
express about neural networks, active
inference, applied, active inference,
computational modeling of perception,
cognition and action, neural networks in
the wild, AI ethics, all these different
areas can hopefully have
a nice discussion in 51.1
and .2. That'll be the last paper
streams for 2022. And yeah,
if you want to be more involved with
live streams whenever you're listening
to this, join or recommend
someone to join or help in any number of
other ways. Just listening
and learning is awesome. And we also
really look forward to those who want to
help make some of these connections that
are latent and sometimes exposed in
these papers and conversations,
and with a few motivated people who want
to connect, for example, to the neural
network communities and those who
can facilitate discussions on these
topics, that would be awesome.
Just using my final thoughts
on this dot zero, because it's always
great to have others also join in the
preparation for the dot zero. So just
want to add that note on this rare solo
stream. So thanks again, looking forward
to talking or seeing you later.